[Music]
did you watch the Grammys last night no
okay
I didn't all the time we've got good
night no I the Grammys make me feel old
it make you feel old yeah it's just you
know all the bands that I like are all
getting like Lifetime Achievement Awards
you know they don't get along with each
other they go up to accept the award
away from me and I don't I don't get
DJ's well like I don't understand DJ's
like they're getting Grammys I'm at that
age like the new music I don't
understand it just to me it's just a guy
playing his iPod with like a mouse head
maybe losing their mind like I don't
know I don't see where the talent is
they blended the song man they took two
songs and blended them yeah see you're
not liking that
well what all you got to do is find two
songs of the same tempo right today like
you're driving down the street and the
highway and you see another guy going as
fast as you and you're like I'd be doing
it
[Applause]
because these guys are selling them out
but I'm just old that I can't tell the
difference between that dude with the
mouse head and the guy he's seen like
the gap ya know that sad guy just
sitting there DJing yeah like a target
well I you guys not go to the same mall
from Target yeah
you your target is a cut above our
target hello Cool J let's talk about him
he was encouraging the fans all night to
interact you I'm guessing that that
you're not gonna go along with that idea
either a fan you know ll can beat up the
Internet
yeah that's why right I I wouldn't
encourage going back and forth of fans I
would say 13% of people on the Internet
are cool the rest of them they're just a
bunch of animals why would you wanna why
would you want to talk to him wait
you're saying only 13% of people are
cool 13% of cool the other 87% are right
in horrific stuff under YouTube videos
they're there they're [ __ ]
the Pope retired oh yeah a little bit
you like that because usually they have
to they stay until they they die that's
it who would want that job just the
pressure like being president it's got
to be the worst job ever just everyday
you know even when you finally get a
break somebody comes over to your house
like the greatest oboe player and you
got to come downstairs and act like you
care
[Applause]
you make any sort of grimace they put it
in the paper not join the oboe player he
doesn't like children what is that gonna
do it's just the worst like I've never
had a TV show successful one that's
actually made it and no and at this
point I realized the genius of it the
genius of head I'm not having a TV show
talking yeah it's awesome when I get to
look at you keep going around saying
that 87 percent of the world sucks
you're not going to get home this is the
thing you say that because there's
nothing you can take away from me you're
gonna say I can't do stand-up in strip
malls anymore
genius no I got it all worked up your
you want to go on other people's shows
yeah it's like when your buddy owns a
boat yeah you don't want to be the guy
who owns the boat you want to be the guy
who shows up with the 12-pack it's the
high five
[Applause]
bill you are welcome you're welcome on
our boat anytime you are hilarious